in this class one of the advantages of
teaching this class is that it was
designed around ten guest lectures which
makes my life I thought easier actually
it doesn't because when you have ten
different people you've got ten
different schedules so the presenter who
was supposed to present tonight Oh about
two weeks ago shifted and changed to
November the 13th so instead of having
her here you're going to hear me tonight
I'm the presenter okay so it has certain
advantages tonight I'm going to talk
about a Harlem during the period of the
1930s and the 1940s and the text I'm
going to read from is my biography of
Malcolm X where the last eight years
I've been doing research on Malcolm X my
biographies entitled Malcolm X a life of
reinvention so I'm going to read a
section from the chapter on detroit red
well Malcolm X in Harlem during the
1940s but before I read that um I wanted
to remind people that again next week
for week six October of the ninth we're
covering the material in week six all
tonight we are not going to go around
and do three minute presentations about
what your papers are but that is going
to be covered during week 9 which is
October the 30th if you look ahead at
your syllabus to page 13 ok so what I'm
going to do tonight is to read from the
paper on Malcolm X and then i'll talk
about Harlem and Malcolm
during the 1940s ok Malcolm little could
not have lived and worked in Harlem
during the Second World War and not have
been affected by that community's
turbulent history and extraordinary
political and cultural activities by any
standard by 1940 Harlem had become the
most cosmopolitan and complex center for
black political activity not only in
black America but throughout the world
roughly one-quarter of Harlem's black
population then consisted of West Indian
immigrants primarily from Jamaica
barbados trinidad British Guiana and
other British colonies nearly all of
whom had established their own political
associations parties and political clubs
of all kinds one of Harlem's most
influential west indian politicians
huland jack originally from st. Lucia
had been elected as a Democrat to
represent the neighborhood in the New
York State Assembly in 1940 Harlem was
also the national center of black labor
activism headed by a Phillip Randolph
who had initiated his legendary career
as a Harlem public orator even before
Marcus Garvey's arrival in the United
States in 1916 thousands of Harlem
residents were active members and
supporters of the Communist Party USA
Harlem ight communists like Claudia
jones and benjamin davis were widely
respected in popular leaders despite the
demise of the Garvey movement Harlem's
militancy had grown more intense chiefly
around grievances concerning economic
issues during the Depression era 1930s
for example black workers in public
laundries
routinely earned three dollars per week
less in wages than whites who performed
identical work employment discrimination
was rampant 1 1922 1928 survey of 250
Harlem businesses employing over 2,000
workers found that only a hundred and
sixty-three employees were black and all
in low-wage jobs as the great depression
deepened black joblessness sword in
Harlem black youth unemployment was
estimated during the 1930s well above
fifty percent in 1935 the federal
government's Works Progress
Administration the WPA which had
determined that the cost of living for
maintaining a New York City household at
maintenance level was 1375 dollars
annually in New York City estimated that
the average black families total income
was only at 1025 dollars the harsh
unequal realities of race and class
prompted the mobilization of Harlem's
black community in 1931 the Harlem
housewives League initiated a campaign
at Harlem chain stores insisting that
they employ african-americans many
Garvey i'ts and black businessmen joined
the new movement urging Negroes to
support a by black effort in 1932 the
Harlem labor union was asked was created
which quickly attracted many black
nationalists and the unemployed West
Indians the Union picketed White's owned
stores in the neighborhood that refused
to hire blacks in 1933 the Citizens
League for fair play was formed a
popular coalition of over 40
organizations
including women's organizations
religious and fraternal groups demanding
greater Negro employment in Harlem
businesses by 1934 these organizing
efforts culminated into mass public
meetings and widespread picket lines in
March 1935 protests sparked a small riot
in Harlem along a hundred and twenty
fifth Street involving several thousand
people dozens of white owned stores were
looted 57 civilians and seven police
officers sustained injuries police
arrested 75 people mostly African
Americans on charges ranging from
inciting to riot felonious assault
malicious mischief and burglary the
NYPD's treatment of the rioters and his
brutal actions in the upheavals
aftermath was subsequently documented by
liberal Republican fusion Mayor Fiorello
laguardia's Commission on conditions in
Harlem police had made derogatory and
threatening remarks one police officer
shot and killed one young black man who
was running without warning another
policeman quote called to arrest an
unarmed drunk hit the drunk so hard that
he died unquote cops illegally carried
out frisks of pedestrians and so called
rioters searching for numbers or policy
slips to bust up Harlem's underground
numbers racket the liberal LaGuardia
administration sought to defuse Harlem's
discontent by implementing many of the
riot commission's recommendations so
from 1936 to 1941 the LaGuardia
administration backed the construction
of two new Harlem schools the Harlem
River houses public housing complex and
the construction of the women's pavilion
at Harlem Hospital LaGuardia consulted
frequently with the black middle classes
moderate political elite notably
national urban league director Lester
Granger an N double ACP executive
secretary Walter White the mayor's
efforts to placate Harlem voters were
recognized in February 1940 when the
local branch of the Association for the
study of Negro life and history honored
him at the Schaumburg collection of the
New York Public Library praising
LaGuardia for quote his efforts to
improve race relations unquote but
laguardia's constructive concessions did
little to alter the widespread poverty
and political discontent among Harlem's
working class and among the unemployed
when the US Supreme Court in 1938
declared that public picketing of
private business is business
establishments over racially based
complaints was constitutional a new
round of Harlem protest ensued the new
don't buy where you can't work coalition
quickly one major concessions from white
businesses within several years about
one-third of all clerks and white-collar
employees in Harlem were
african-american in parallel efforts
Black Swan employment concessions to
work as telephone repairmen and
operators to drive buses for the Fifth
Avenue and the New York omnibus
companies and to hold white-collar
positions in Consolidated Edison which
was a company that blacks were largely
excluded from prior to nineteen forty
what is most significant about Harlem
struggles during the 30s in the early
40s is that Harlem established a model
of social reform
and urban protest that would later be
replicated across America during the
civil rights era two decades later in
the case of Harlem mass agitation mostly
by grassroots associations and
organizations unions and churches around
specific racial grievances culminated
first in a series of well-publicized
public demonstrations second these were
followed by urban insurrection third a
liberal government whether local or
federal supported by white and Negro
elites subsequently negotiates
concessions in the form of new hospitals
public housing expanded Negro
opportunities for employment in both the
public in the private sector those
reforms in turn spawned the political
environment for the rise of the new
African American victories with in
electoral politics the courts and the
government the key elements of what
became the protest strategy for winning
locally based reforms during the civil
rights movement a generation later were
conceived not in Birmingham Montgomery
or Atlanta or in rural Mississippi but
they were largely framed and conceived
by the struggles around the tenements of
Harlem during the 1930s and the 1940s in
effect many of the strategies in the
protests and the tactics that we think
of belonging to the 60s and the civil
rights movement actually respond and
created in the early 40s right here in
Harlem
the primary political beneficiary be
successful political reforms in Harlem
if one had to choose one individual was
the Reverend Adam Clayton Powell jr.
morn in 1908 Powell was the son of the
powerful pastor of Harlem's Abyssinia
Baptist Church Adam Clayton Powell
senior educated at Colgate University in
upstate New York and Columbia
University's Teachers College Powell jr.
followed his father into the ministry
but his overriding interests were hardly
spiritual in 1931 young Powell led a
protest at new york city's Board of
estimates that successfully halted the
exclusion of five african-american
physicians from practicing at Harlem
Hospital in 1938 Powell had joined with
Randolph and others to launch the
Greater New York Coordinating Committee
for employment which used pickets and
nonviolent protests to secure African
American jobs succeeding his father as
Abyssinians pastor in 1937 Powell
possessed a strong religious
constituency as well as a growing army
of political supporters and volunteers
for his many causes ideologically and
politically Powell was a pragmatic
liberal in Harlem Powell worked
frequently and cooperatively with a
communist party at the national level he
endorsed Roosevelt's New Deal
administration locally he supported
legore diaz reelection campaign as mayor
in 1941 although LaGuardia was
technically a Republican that same year
Powell started the People's Committee a
Harlem based mast organization of 1800
campaign workers and eight offices
dedicated to the election of the
charismatic minister to the New York
City Council Powell's challengers on the
left and the right American Labour Party
candidate dr. max Juergen of City
College and Republican candidate chanted
Channing Tobias respectively pulled out
of the contest in powell's favor
LaGuardia and dirt endorsed Powell and
the two liberals campaigned together
both achieving victory once elected to
City Council however Powell astutely
used his post to promote Harlem's
continuing grievances when jurgen a
history instructor at the nearly
all-white City College located in West
Harlem was not reappointed to his
academic position largely on political
grounds Powell introduced in February
1941 resolution number 31 demanding the
banning of racial discrimination in
academic appointments at City University
at the City College in May 1942 Powell's
organization sponsored a mass rally at
the Golden Gate ballroom to protest NYPD
brutality in the beating and killing of
a young black man Wallace Armstrong in
January 1943 when the LaGuardia
administration granted the US Navy
permission to establish training
facilities for the racially segregated
women's reserve the waves at manhattan's
hunter college and Walton High School
pal bitterly denounced the action as a
hypocritical capitulation to the federal
government's segregationist Jim Crow
policies Powell's bold position was
embraced by civil rights organizations
by black labor and by the communists
because it represented what they called
the double the
campaign double v victory abroad and
victory over racism at home championing
the defeat of both fascism and racial
discrimination in response to blacks
modest gains in employment thousands of
white workers participated in what are
called hate strikes hate strikes during
the war demanding the exclusion of
Negroes especially from skilled
positions and nog in July 1943 white
racists briefly paralyzed Baltimore's
Bethlehem shipyards at Sparrows Point
because of the threat of Negroes being
hired only the results resolute action
by the liberal Congress of Industrial
Organizations the CIO unions that were
involved as well as the shipbuilders
electricians and steel workers
suppressed the hate strike in August
1944 Philadelphia white street car
drivers outraged at the assignment of
eight black motormen staged a six-day
strike that shut down public
transportation in Philadelphia in
response President Roosevelt dispatched
5,000 troops into Philadelphia and
issued an executive order placing the
streetcar company under army control
this is all over the hiring of eight
black men the city shut down during a
war it's unbelievable none of these
events were lost upon african-americans
many of whom now questioned their
participation and support for America's
war effort years later novelist James
Baldwin recalled quote the treatment
accorded to the Negro during the Second
World War marks from me a turning point
in the Negroes relationship to America a
certain hope died
a certain respect for white Americans
faded unquote thousands of young
african-american males began refusing to
register for the draft others sought to
disqualify themselves from military
service due to health reasons or other
disabilities one obscure black religious
sect the Nation of Islam led by
middle-aged Negro male calling himself
Elijah Muhammad openly exhort adha
lowers to refuse to register for the
draft in September 1942 the FBI rounded
up nearly 100 African Americans for
draft resistance the defendants belonged
to three organizations the Nation of
Islam the Brotherhood of Liberty for
black people of America and the peace
movement of Ethiopia when questioned by
the FBI Liza Mohammed brass newly stated
that for the record that quote Allah has
taught has taught that blueprints of a
plane which carries bombs was given to
the Japanese from the holy city of Mecca
and that these blueprints had been there
for thousands of years these moms would
go into the earth at least a mile and
would throw up earth for a distance of
one mile so that it would make a
mountain quote unquote the majority of
those arrested claimed to be Muslims 56
defendants were tried convicted and
received three-year prison terms one son
of elijah muhammad emmanuel kareem was
given five years in prison Elijah
Muhammad was charged with sedition
following his conviction Elijah Muhammad
remained incarcerated and federal pen
attention a federal penitentiary until
his release in August 1946 back in
Harlem on April the 22nd 1943 the Savoy
Ballroom was padlocked by the NYPD
on the alleged grounds that servicemen
had been solicited by prostitutes on its
premises the Savoy's closing had been
prompted by Assistant Police
Commissioner Cornelius O'Leary who
justified the action because of concerns
over public health New York City's
Bureau of social hygiene had cited
evidence that over a nine-month period
in nineteen forty-two forty-three
thousand one hundred and sixty four
individuals quote have met the source of
their venereal disease at the Savoy
Ballroom unquote 43,000 people okay
these alleged cases came from Navy Army
and Marines and Coast Guard personnel as
historian Russell gold has observed
quote this is suspect testimony because
no evidence was provided to explain how
they knew that their service men or
other citizens had contracted their
venereal diseases from prostitutes at
the Savoy instead of from their wives
girlfriends or contacts with prostitutes
elsewhere unquote good point when on
April the twentieth nineteen forty-three
the Appellate Division of the new york
state supreme court ruled unanimously to
uphold or Leary's actions mayor
LaGuardia declared that he was powerless
to stop the Savoy's closing he said my
hands are tied so the Savoy shut down
why was this significant since his grand
opening on March to 12 1926 the Savoy
Ballroom located on lenox avenue between
140 and 140 first Street quickly became
the most significant cultural and social
institution of Harlem and arguably of
New York City the great ballroom spanned
an entire city
block to large band stands richly
carpeted lounges and mirrored walls were
in the building at the Savoy heyday
about 700,000 customers came to dance
came to the dance mecca every year
during the 1930s the Savoy became the
palace of big bands jazz music and
dancing no Harlem I could ever forget
the legendary big band battle between
Chick Webb and Benny Goodman's
orchestras on May the 11th 1937 Chick
Webb won by the way in 1943 the Savoy's
exclusive patrons numbered between five
to seven thousand two thirds of whom
were african-americans these included
Orson Welles Greta Garbo Lana Turner and
even the rising Republican star in the
state named Thomas Dewey who would soon
be elected governor hundreds of Harlem
civic and social organizations readied
the Savoy for their activities in a
period when downtown hotels and dance
halls still remain segregated the Savoy
was the principal cultural center for
interracial dancing and entertainment
the reaction of Harlem's political elite
to the Savoy's closing was fierce
Powell's newspaper the People's Voice
headlined what's behind the Savoy
closing is it police move to bar whites
from Harlem the People's Voice launched
its own investigation of quote downtown
dance holes predictably finding that
prostitution downtown was widespread the
Savoy Ballroom remained closed
throughout the summer of nineteen
forty-three on October the fifteenth
nineteen forty-three police announced
that the establishments license had been
renewed and the Savoy's grand
reopening occurred on October the 22nd
1943 for Malcolm little the public
debate over the closing of the Savoy was
clear evidence of the limitations of
white liberalism's racial tolerance this
is what Malcolm says in his
autobiography quote during world war two
Mayor LaGuardia officially closed the
Savoy Ballroom Harlem said the real
reason was to stop Negroes from dancing
with white women Harlem said no one drag
white women in there Adam Clayton Powell
made a big fight he had successfully
fought Consolidated Edison and the New
York telephone company until they hired
Negroes then he had then he had helped
to battle the US Navy in the US Army
about their segregating they're
segregating of uniform Negroes but
Powell couldn't win this battle City
Hall just kept the Savoy closed for a
long time it was just another one of
those liberal north actions that didn't
help Harlem to love the white man any
unquote only weeks following the sub all
ballrooms closing in May 1943 the
LaGuardia administration made public its
agreement with Metropolitan Life
Insurance Company to construct
Stuyvesant Town a semi public housing
complex located on the lower east side
of manhattan MetLife had received from
the city generous tax exemptions eminent
domain authority and control of tenant
selection when it became clear that
Metropolitan Life Insurance intended to
keep black tenants out no blacks could
live in stuyvesant town African
Americans and many white liberals were
outraged Powell accused LaGuardia of
once again capitulating to white racism
his newspaper boldly editorialized quote
Hitler won a victory
in New York City and one mass rally that
attracted 20,000 people Powell demanded
labore Diaz impeachment it was not until
1944 that LaGuardia brokered a so-called
compromise stuyvesant town was
constructed under the original terms
with metropolitan life insurance however
the mayor signed local law number 20
barring all future racial discrimination
in tenant selection for housing projects
constructed under the city's authority
by private corporations when the Detroit
race riot of june nineteen forty-three
erupted New York City's authorities
should have recognized that the
conditions for a similar insurrection
were ripe in Harlem in only its first
six hours the toll from Detroit's unrest
amounted to 34 deaths over seven hundred
injured with two million dollars of
property damage five thousand federal
troops were needed and sent into Detroit
to patrol the city streets military
vehicles were assigned to escort trolley
cars and buses Harlem's turn came on
August the first 1943 when a policeman
shot a black service man in uniform
Robert vandy who was attempting to
protect his mother from police arrest
rumors that bandy had been murdered
prompted thousands of Harlem i'ts into
the streets seeking retaliation within
minutes general rioting erupted
white-owned businesses along one hundred
and twenty fifth street and on Harlem's
major north-south boulevards lenox
seventh and eighth avenues north from
Central Park up to 140 fifth Street were
attacked hundreds of businesses within
minutes before midnight 1450 stores
been vandalized and looted six people
had been killed nearly 200 people
seriously injured over 600 Negroes were
incarcerated by the NYPD significantly
unlike the 1935 race riot eyewitness
accounts of the 1943 insurrection
described the rioters as both middle
class as well as lower-class Negroes
even one 1943 police report of the
violence recognized quote those actually
committing malicious acts of violence
were irresponsible ignorant individuals
but the probability is that many decent
citizens were in various groups who in
the most instances are intelligent and
law abiding and while not actually
taking part in the physical disturbance
aided and abetted indirectly and said
disturbances unquote so in effect the
overwhelming majority of middle-class
blacks supported the rioting they were
angry they were fed up with the
administration they were tired of the
police brutality and they were tired of
the racial discrimination that was
supported by the laguardia
administration in the aftermath of the
riot Malcolm little was walking sorry oh
the on the afternoon of the riot the
insurrection Malcolm little was walking
south on saint nicholas avenue when he
observed negroes running uptown quote
loaded down with armfuls of stuff
unquote along west 120 fifth Street he
soon discovered quote Negroes were
smashing store windows and taking
everything that could grab and carry
furniture food jewelry clothes whiskey
unquote within an hour the NYPD
dispatched what appeared to Malcolm to
quote every new york city cop in Harlem
Malcolm colorfully described the semi
comic scene of n-double-a-cp head walter
white accompanying the diminutive mayor
LaGuardia driving along 125th Street in
a huge bright red fire car pleading over
loudspeakers to all of those quote
shouting milling angry Negroes to please
go home and stay inside unquote Malcolm
probably would have agreed with Powell's
explanation about bandys reasons for
resisting arrest by the NYPD this is
what Powell had to say quote he was not
mad with him only for arresting a
colored woman but he was mad with every
white police officer in the United
States who had consistently beaten
wounded and often killed colored men and
women without provocation when rioters
were smashing windows they thought they
were breaking the skulls of race haters
and race baiters unquote it is from that
vantage point of Harlem's mounting
racial grievances unemployment
discrimination widespread unemployment
the controversial closing of the Savoy
Ballroom the Stuyvesant Town agreement
and the August 1943 race riot that
Malcolm's littles actions regarding his
military induction should come should be
considered in the autobiography of
malcolm x Malcolm recalled shorty
Jarvis's attitude about the outbreak of
world war two approvingly this is what
shorty said quote white he owns
everything he wants us to go and bleed
for him let him fight unquote although
the autobiography makes no mention of it
Malcolm little may have heard about the
well-publicized case of an African
American Winfred w Lin who had refused
to be inducted in September 19 for
too because of his opposition to
racially segregated military units Lynn
eventually lost his case but his protest
had provoked widespread sympathy among
black Americans by 1943 1944 dissent
among blacks within the Armed Services
had escalated hundreds of black soldiers
were simply going AWOL from their
segregated army units there were also
according to historian Harvard sit cough
an unusually high number of casualties
experienced by white officers of
segregated black units in other words
fragging officers right when the
military's induction notice addressed to
Malcolm little arrived at his sister
Ellis Ella Collins's home in Boston in
Roxbury she had informed authorities
that her half-brother no longer resided
there when Malcolm eventually received
the notice of induction he decided he
would avoid military service by any
means necessary the legend of detroit
red depicted in the autobiography of
malcolm x presents a classic trickster
tale of guile comedic deception and
ultimate vindication for the hero quote
i had about ten days before i had to
show up at the induction Center Malcolm
rights I went right to work Malcolm knew
that Harlem was filled with military
intelligence soldiers quote those black
spies and civilian clothes he spread out
the word on the streets that quote I was
frantic to join the Japanese army of the
date of his scheduled induction October
twenty-fifth nineteen forty-three
Malcolm wrote quote a costume like an
actor with my wild zoot suit I wore the
yellow knob toed shoes and I frizzled my
hair up into a reddish bush of conch he
addressed 11 white soldier sitting at
the reception desk crazy Oh dad
give me give me moving I can't wait to
get into that brown eventually pulled
from the induction line the zoot suited
hustler was interrogated by a military
psychiatrist to determine his fitness to
serve Malcolm Reynold rambled
incessantly then Malcolm astutely
whispered in the psychiatrist ear daddy
oh now you and me we're from up north
here so don't you tell nobody I want to
get sent down south organize them niggas
soldiers you dig steal some guns and
kill us some crackers the psychiatrist's
done senseless uttered that will be all
the military psychiatrist judge Malcolm
little as four F unfit for military duty
a ok a 4f card came to me in the mail
Malcolm concluded triumph elite quote
and I never heard from the Army anymore
and never bothered to ask why I was
rejected unquote a subsequent FBI report
dated january twenty eighth nineteen
fifty-five confirms that Malcolm little
was rejected quote the subject was found
mentally disqualified for military
service for the following reasons
psychopathic personality inadequate
sexual perversion psychiatric rejection
the subject was classified four F on
december four 1944 unquote the FBI
memorandum suggests that certain erotic
elements of Detroit Reds trickster tale
the curious issue of sexual perversion
were deleted from Malcolm's own version
of what had actually transpired there
was also a certain connection between
the comedic zoot suit performance at his
at the induction Center and Malcolm's
sandwich read routine for months that he
had worked when he was working on the
rail
Road both were disingenuous performances
of black buffoonery designed to achieve
different objectives financial reward
and a permanent deferment from military
service but both costume personas
directly repudiated the militant
assertive black model provided by his
father the marcus garvey eight they also
contradicted Malcolm's own growing
political attitudes and evolving social
consciousness especially in the wake of
the 1943 harlem race riot Adam Clayton
Powell juniors dramatic leadership
during these years also deeply impressed
young Malcolm as subsequent events which
show in the 1950s and 60s when x 63 a
coalition is formed between Black Muslim
Malcolm X and congressman Adam Powell
the hustlers Creed of getting over
through the art of deception
fundamentally conflicted with the
political heritage of Malcolm's parents
and the example of Powell ultimately
Malcolm little who would become Malcolm
X would have to decide which model of
black masculinity he would claim for
himself so that's the essay um what you
get from the story is that Malcolm was
largely formed by the experiences that
he had in Harlem during World War two
but I also wanted to get across the kind
of political and social and cultural
dynamic of this important black
neighborhood during this critical time
as we discussed last week although most
of what people know about Harlem really
involves the Harlem Renaissance in the
literature in the art of the 1920s one
can make a very good case that Harlem
that we think of
is the kind of archetypal the template
for black urbanism is really formed not
so much in the 20s but more so during
the Depression and World War two and the
immediate aftermath in the 1930s and the
1940s so let me stop you have any
questions everybody is like chill today
yeah do I see a head no hands yes you
have a hand or is what was the response
of the LaGuardia administration they
tried to but you know black folk were
very angry and low watt and LaGuardia
had messed up so many times so once
again you have another Commission you
have certain kinds of concessions black
people in part in Harlem responded by
ratcheting up the militancy and they did
it in a couple ways one Powell gets
elected to Congress the very next year
in 1944 he becomes the second black
person in Congress and he serves in that
capacity for a quarter of a century
second they elect benjamin davis jr who
is the leader of the Communist Party in
Harlem to replace Powell in the City
Council so Harlem is represented by a
communist in the City Council so it
shows the level of militancy and
political development within this
neighborhood so that's part of what
we're really looking at
yes was what he yes I'm not really sure
that I don't know but you know Powell
pressed of the City Council all to
initiate legislation to wipe out a
discrimination at all kinds of levels
perhaps Powell was inspired by
Roosevelt's executive order 8802 which
had been of essentially signed by
roosevelt in july 1941 that outlawed
racial discrimination in hiring policies
by of military contractors that held
federal defense contracts executive
order 8802 was the foundation of what we
today call affirmative-action an equal
employment equal opportunity employment
legislation because what Roosevelt did
was to establish the principle that
businesses that have a federal contract
could not carry out racial
discrimination in hiring this was the
first time in American history where a
president actually took this position
and enforced it and it had a huge impact
on hiring of something like 750,000
Negroes were hired by defense
contractors during World War two other
questions
yes
yes it's a sad story of a black motormen
were hired white of motor men were
outraged that nigger's were hired for
white men's jobs and so they had a
strike where they refused to to drive
the of the trolleys in Philadelphia and
the pasilla was paralyzed for six days
couldn't go to work couldn't get to
hospital couldn't go to school it was
the trolleys that actually carried
people back then and so Roosevelt had to
send in five thousand federal troops
this is all over 88 black employees
that's it so if I want to convey to you
you guys who live who were born after of
the civil rights era the depths of white
racism in this country and the reality
of how deep it was that you would
paralyze an entire city costing millions
of dollars of economic production during
wartime over eight black men being hired
but that's what happened in Philadelphia
not Philadelphia Mississippi in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania city of
brotherly love
if you think it was bad in Philadelphia
just imagine what would have happened in
Atlanta or in Birmingham you know the
three black men would have been lynched
other questions okay so what I tried to
do you had another question maybe yes
right Tom Dewey open it up not that i
don't know maybe do we did maybe do we
like to swing or stomp you know there's
that wonderful there's that wonderful
song stompin at the Savoy you know uh by
uh Ellington I believe you know but um
the Savoy was like a mecca for dance
it's hard to really convey but think of
a place that attracts 700,000 dancers in
every year you know they had to replace
the ballroom floor of the Savoy once
every three years you know on the floor
was like this but they would wear out
the floor and they had to put in a whole
new floor because people would just use
it up right ah this was the era of swing
dance you have big bands at two stages
the thing was massive a whole city block
right an entire city block with a dance
floor that was absolutely massive with
mirrors on the wall or plush carpeting
just incredible right in the center of
Harlem yes
ah yes good question right right um I'm
not really so much bothered by that of
the fact that we're the Savoy was has
been turned into now I guess a luxury
apartment um you know you close your
eyes for a second in harlem now under
gentrification you have a whole new
thing you know i saw the the new
building at 140 fifth and west uh no 130
where's that one hundred thirty fifth
and seventh avenue right this is like a
building there yeah right unlike the
northwest corner or the north yeah the
northwest corner but um i'm not so much
bothered by that my problem is that when
i walk on Fifth Avenue at between where
is that 45th and forty forty fourth and
45th street on Fifth Avenue that that
was the site of the Nick the colored
asylum for children during the Civil War
and that's where 400 black children were
burned alive by rioting whites during
the Civil War I don't believe there's a
marker there right is there a marker
when you walk to the bottom of wall
street wear it wear it converges with
the East River that this was one of the
largest slave of slave markets in the
new world for like a hundred years I
don't think there's a marker there so
this is why in part black history gets
eradicated
oi distorted and so the city makes no
effort they have monuments to all kinds
of people all kinds of criminals very
rarely are their markers to everyday
people and the ordeals that they have
gone through here in the city or
anyplace else in this country there's a
monument to slavery or the transatlantic
slave trade in the United States not
that I know of and yet involve millions
of people and it took place over
hundreds of years did you ever think
about that yeah but those are the
Africans who died when they got here I'm
talking about the transatlantic slave
trade all right the slave trade itself
there's nothing nowhere in the country I
know this is kind of a downer
conversation perhaps we should end on a
lighter note i had a feeling we would
probably hidden early all right what we
were trying to do is set the tone for
what Harlem was like and why was
significant during this period now next
week we're going to talk about the
international dimensions of Harlem we
haven't talked about East Harlem Latino
Harlem you're going to be reading
material on that but we haven't talked
yet about the African connections with
Harlem and so we're going to see Harlem
transnationally in the reading now in
one month you guys have to come up with
what you want your paper to be or what
your topic will be you've been reading
different materials you've had an
opportunity to think about it but I
would really like it if within the next
two weeks you cut you actually come up
with what you want to do because you
will definitely need the period of time
between mid-october to the end of
november
put it together if you wait until the
end of October you're only going to have
four weeks that may not be enough time
okay so you should be thinking about
your papers you have any other questions
any other comments okay John was a lot
quicker than I fought so I only prepared
for about an hour yes no I didn't say
that one quarter one quarter yeah I saw
that um I don't I don't really agree
with that because I think that what
happens especially for um Caribbean
immigrants is that there's a dynamic of
the first generation and the second
generation this is an oversimplification
and Horace you can correct me if I'm
wrong but my own impression is that the
first the first generation of immigrants
frequently still identifies themselves
with the country they came from and so
they're here to pick up some money to
earn money ship it back home and then
return home but what happens is that
next year they always plan to return
home next year next year it never comes
right and the next thing you know 30
years has gone by and it raised the
family and their kids have grown up and
they are now living in the United States
but there is still death Nikoli they
still read ethnic newspapers they still
may speak the same language they spoke
with in their country there's still an
intense identification with what
happened what's happening in the mother
country
the second generation of immigrants have
a very different outlook they're
socialized in the United States they
have expectations of Americans
nationally all they may feel a deep
sense of cultural and social connection
with where their parents came from but
they're not going to go back to that
country because they never were from
that country they're from here and so
their expectations are here and
frequently usually they intermarry with
people who are also frequently
hyphenated Americans or
african-americans and so by the third
generation and also there's one other
thing to consider that in the United
States the great equalizer for Black
folk who are immigrants is white
supremacy that is that you get judged
not by your language not by where you
from ethnically not by what your
passport says but by the color of your
skin and it's not your fault is the
fault of white racism so that if you're
Abner Louima from Haiti or your amadou
diallo from Guinea doesn't matter to the
NYPD right they don't ask what where
you're from or none of that and so
racism Trump's those things and young
second generation of black Americans who
are from that whose ancestry is from
outside of the United States get treated
and are related to my you know people
like the NYPD as black Americans no
matter what you say you are you can say
whatever you want to say your
black American as far as they're
concerned and so consequently since your
life chances are affected by that you
begin to see the world through your life
chances just like any normal person does
right you have to navigate your life
within the society in which you find
yourself maybe not the one you want to
be in but the one you are it that's what
changes things so my wife was born in
Jamaica is proud of her Jamaican
heritage I love Jamaican culture but
she's a black American and she functions
that way that doesn't negate who she is
culturally is just the reality of her
life because that's the reality of
racism and if you have something in your
head like Abner Louima if you have
something in your head that says hey I
can be protected from that stuff you're
crazy right because it doesn't work that
way right it just doesn't maybe Clarence
Thomas it works that way I don't know
yeah you know I wish you've worked in a
different way okay